i mean i manifest i see things
i'm a great leader because i listen
and i'm empathetic
and
i feel
the entire earth and i feel us as a as a
species as the the human race i do
believe in
world peace no matter what religion you
are what we can agree on is it is always
now
but now is the shortest moment of our
life
it's gone in an instant the longest
moments of our life are our memories
and our imaginations
my mother had a decent job you know what
i'm saying but she
gave me a little allowance 15 20 a week
and i had to go out and get my own job
at age 15. matter of fact at 14 i was
cutting hair in a barber shop so it was
instilled in me to go out and just get
it and that may be me be a leader around
a lot of black men like even my father
had i had two fathers in my life i had
my real father that i was in contact
with and my stepfather that stayed there
with my mother and everybody was
instilling that responsibility in me
that nothing in life is given to you a
lot of times i feel like a lot of people
just rapping because it's free like i'm
gonna use everything that everybody says
that i can't do or and i'm gonna flip it
to the positive like i look at
everything as a glass half full and then
half empty and i feel like 10 percent of
life is what happens to you 90 is how
you react to it i'm gonna take this
opportunity like i got some songs i got
some stuff in my heart that the world
needs to hear
positive affirmation everyone agrees
that we are energy right carbon yeah
and we have electricity everyone knows
we have electric currents flowing
through our body our brain moves at
30 hertz at a time of crisis
when it's an alpha where 10 to 12 hurts
when we go to delta which is sleep mode
we're about four hertz and stuff and
this is like the thing i've just been
this far yay swag on it i'm telling
people we are the atomic bomb that tesla
was talking about but in order to be
that but we're atomic mom of love right
in order to be that
we have to
unprogram
and move forward and be a kinetic energy
and
use positivity and positive thoughts
it's literally that simple i went from
having confidence and arrogance to
having faith and faith is the opposite
of fear and that created this
fearless approach that i have and that's
what made now has made me
the fearless leader that i am that i've
like
crystallized into
the leader that my mom always knew i
would be when kids followed me in
preschool everyone across the globe no
matter what
country in the world whatever
continental world all of the moms and
dads have something in common they want
the world to be better for their
children we all want the world to be
better for the children and
we can show ways that we are not at odds
think about the world is a giant piano
but we're playing off-key
because the greatest thing that a man
has to give to anyone whether it's their
kids whether it's their wife
is time
and how much time do we spend
you know chasing the american dream
we're chasing money and materialistic
things how much time do we actually give
to the women and children
there's a lot of people that make the
same thing or more than people with
college degrees and ultimately it's
about being happy having a happy life
raising your family i feel like the key
to life is family itself so if you can
provide for your family and this is
speaking from a male point of view and
be happy
then that's that's all you need it's not
about that college degree that everybody
says that you you're supposed to have it
so many people with college degrees that
are not happy with their life if you
have a dream
and you're good enough because sometimes
people it's a difference between a dream
and just being delusional don't just
drop out of school like i was already
making money in the music industry i had
a i had a platinum plaque
before i dropped out of school and i had
a deal on the table with columbia with
sony anything in life that you put your
mind to
you can do the world the world is your
oyster that's all i tell people and i
really have a grasp of that being that i
nearly died
it's it's this
and it's heaven
why you're on earth
especially if you're not incarcerated
you got to take advantage of this and
that doesn't mean for everybody to be a
rapper for everybody to be a producer
do what you do to the fullest and live
your life and just and just be happy
i'm ready to go in it's one of those
like jumping in the deep end things like
if you knew
how
you know difficult certain things were
you might not jump in to be able to
receive
be able to receive how rewarding they
are on the other end
if you have the opportunity
to play this game of life
you need to appreciate every moment
a lot of people don't appreciate that
moment
until it's passed
we have to understand that we're not
each other's enemy we have to stop
discriminating against each other due to
class and due to race and due to
location of financial you know position
we have to say
wow that is the best version let's use
it let's bring it let's bring it to
light let's move forward let's push
forward as a civil a civilization
because we're so
jacked up on our own egos and so
misguided by mainstream you know
marketing
we don't know what the [ __ ] is real we'd
be apt to get into a fight this quick
for the dumbest reason
you know we we it's like we're pitted
against each other we're we're mentally
not in a place to be accepting to not be
jealous and that part of that jealousy
and that frustration that that that that
goes up
across an entire globe is due to some of
these other
high corporation
level limitations that i've like tried
to open up so that creators can be more
empowered because i believe the world
can be
saved or helped in the world meaning us
as human beings our civilization us as a
race as one race can be helped through
align people with
motives of
with more positive motives
and who see more colors than just green
to
help be at least a part of the
conversation and be heard and listen to
the toll point like not being hurt be
heard and listen to i kind of like pain
i like the challenge i like making
things harder
for myself because if you can beat the
game on the hardest mode possible
you know then you'll be the best of all
time my life is philanthropy when i wake
up it's philanthropy everything i'm
doing is thinking how can i you know
help others so if you think about things
i've got like the most backlash forward
i was actually trying to help others
maybe in the wrong way maybe a long time
maybe this but really trying to fight
for what i could see or what i thought
was the truth bravery is not like not
having fear it's overcoming uh the fear
so i feel like i'm a bit
uh similar to a brave heart of
creativity you know i want to teach the
creators to fight for their ideas
because so many times creatives are you
know you picture them being in the back
of the corner like uh somebody snatching
their sketch out and like kicking it
down or something or because you got
this perception of the creatives and san
fran is one of great places to express
how creativity could then become the
center of the world rap is just a
chamber of my thoughts it's something
that i really wanted to express as a
modern day
you know poet
because you know if i lived in a past
lifetime maybe i would have been a
playwright or something but in this
lifetime to be the most turnt the most
relevant the most relevant is to be a
rap rock star right you know i'm saying
you can express you know at the highest
level then for me i like i came from you
know art school and everything i would
you know draw out all these ideas and
all these concepts and the the more and
more i get to create the younger and
younger and younger i feel so you know
when i did glow in the dark i felt you
know i felt like i was five years old
you